Any advice for a person with intense chronic pain that wants to become,
who wants to become a uh,
uh,
oh,
sorry,
it switched on the other we go crayola sheeps has any advice for a person with
intense chronic pain who wants to become a contributing member of society,
specifically having the self discipline to push through pain,
to take care of responsibilities?
Well,
the first thing I would say is that if you have intense chronic pain,
them,
my heart goes out to you because that's really awful.
And so I think that you can cut yourself a break.
I think the fact that you want to become or continue being a contributing member
to society of society is a testament to your fortitude.
I guess the first thing I would ask you is if your pain has been reasonably
managed,
you probably know this,
and I'm not giving you any medical advice because I can't,
but you might want to note that there are antidepressants that are quite
effective as longterm pain medications,
and you may already know that,
but if you don't,
then you should check that out because they're not addictive and they can be a
very effective adjunct.
I would also say that the literature on chronic pain tends to indicate that more
activity is better than less and that,
and that's partly because when you get engaged in something that's meaningful,
let's say,
and important to you,
that that activates the dopaminergic system,
the same system that cocaine activate sound that can produce a fairly pronounced
analgesic effect.
So I would say everything that you can do to get yourself occupied with things
that you regard as important and worthwhile is actually probably going to help
you manage your pain better.
It looks like inactivity is a bad,
is bad.
Generally speaking,
for chronic pain,
I mean,
obviously that's not the case.
If the sort of activity that you're engaged in is of the type that will
aggravate an underlying chronic physiological condition.
But I would say,
uh,
make a plan,
make a daily plan,
make a weekly plan,
um,
make it,
you know,
push yourself a little bit farther than you can go comfortably on a weekly basis
and see how far you can get any year.
That's because,
what's your choice?
I mean,
you're laying there,
suffering is not preferable to doing things and suffering,
not generally.
So I would say like more power to you for trying and,
but,
but also do keep in mind that activity,
meaningful activity is a good analgesic.
So,
um,
Eric Butler says,
sheesh Canadians never get it.
Well,
I didn't know we'd get it.
Sometimes there are,
come on now,
you know,
give us a break.
We're just,
Canadians were freezing to death half the time.
So,
you know,
we do pretty well given the fact that every day here in the winter is the
equivalent of a national catastrophe in the u s so anyways,
um,
Betsy Kirk lender says,
if the second amendment is taken away,
there will be nothing to protect your freedom of speech.
That is how important it is.
Yes,
well not is certainly the argument that people who are,
um,
motivated to protect the second amendment make.
And I'm not going to oppose that.
So.